let's see two
number six
what is it one
good question
foreign
all right six eight
nine ten all right it looks like we're
good
all right task for next week is to find
out what a Purim is
good afternoon good afternoon
or sit wherever you like your name tags
hey
all right sorry about the uh
cancellation last week
I heard the temperature in the this room
was over 90 and that would have uh
not have been Pleasant for anybody
so uh has everyone had an opportunity to
okay good
motor proof
second second okay move by uh senator
seconded by by Senator Bradley any
comments Corrections or additions to the
minutes
all right seeing Nando's in favor
aye
opposed
all right we have minutes
um
Mr Carlin you have the reports from the
actuaries on the Amendments we sent out
a while back
if you could
present them to us we'd like to see what
the effects are of those
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system
um you should have all received a
document uh from Bradley
um Greenland with uh a couple of pieces
attached in one document one the first
cover sheet is sort of a summary of the
numbers in the GRS Actuarial valuation
of the amendment than the text of the
actual amendment is uh brought to the
committee last month and then finally
the full GRS report we thought it would
be uh more effective to organize it in
one document because if you didn't know
how to read the GRS report you wouldn't
notice skip the first seven pages and
start concentrating on it when you start
seeing the numbers and then you can kind
of read backwards from there
um so starting with uh 2258
um
used to go in numerical order uh this
amendment changed the multiplier for all
of the group two trb members uh to two
and a half percent
um so the the scale of the 2.4 2.3 2.2
2.1 went away
um and um also had a parallel language
so that those multipliers apply to the
disability calculations as well
um so what what GRS you know they they
run these scenarios you know through
their model and apply the assumptions
for you know the demographics of the
group and and things like that and that
they generate their report so the class
pieces I
um
pdf'd onto the first page here just just
for the raw numbers but essentially if
2258 was introduced and adopted and
signed into law with no funding at all
the employer contribution rates as a
percentage of payroll would go up that's
the first line on the top page of the
Plus 1.67 or Plus 1.57 for fire and the
next line there represents based on the
covered payroll
um
of those of that of the of group two
that's how much more employers would be
contributing and again that's that's
spread across all employers
um based on the size of their payroll
for these respective groups so it's it's
a proportional cost the total 8.9
million obviously we knew from committee
deliberations it wasn't a desire to pass
the full cost on to employers through
the rates so uh the next line three uaal
that's the unfunded portion of the of
restoring this benefit multiplier
um you know uh to to the to the group
um that's typically where during the
legislative session most of the analyzes
ends how much is the ual piece because
there is a future normal cost for
benefit accruals
um and that's what the the next line is
employer normal class with ual
pre-funded so what that means is if the
state were if this bill was to pass and
the state provided
um you know 62.6 million there still
would be an impact on employer rates but
it would be significantly lower be about
a third of what it was with no
pre-funding
and that um
amounts shown right below in actual
dollars projected for FY 26.
um and then finally and this came up at
the committee's last meeting with the
discussion of terminal funding and what
that actually means so so terminal
funding is basically the actuary is
projecting all of the past the unfunded
costs plus what the future normal costs
would be
um you know uh calculated back into
today's dollars so that's that's the
largest number there and that's the
bottom line and normally if you're
changing benefits
um for any of the groups in the
retirement system you it's uh it would
be practically impossible to terminal
fund because as new hire is entering and
accruing these benefits and things like
that but but since this is essentially a
closed group of you know 1800 give or
take people you know the actuary was
able to calculate a terminal funding
cost so that bottom line uh terminal
funding costs no rate impact is the
equivalent of saying if
there's a consensus to do this and
there's a consensus for the employers to
pay nothing extra you know the state
would write us a check for that amount
and you know we'd all leave and we'd be
done
um so that that's sort of the the
shorthand version of that and and the
same
um pieces apply for 22.59 in terms of
concept the numbers
for 22.59 are
um less uh partially because the
multiplier is is a change in a graduated
way so it only reverts to 2.25 for those
with less than five years
at the time of the change
um
so that's kind of the difference between
the two and that that's what the numbers
mean I hope I
didn't go too fast so please anybody
um
we can
roll it back if needed
are there any questions from the
committee
wow
Senator Bradley uh thank you very much
so
um
so this bottom line number on 2259 and
2258 of 92.6 and 59.1
that is similar to how the benefit was
funded in House Bill 1587 terminally
funding no great impact is that correct
actually 1587 the 43 million last year
for that bill approximately 43 million
that was just the unfunded piece so
there was a slight increase in the
normal cost for that one this this one
is funding at an even higher level okay
than that but it's analogous yes okay
excellent job Mr Carlin I don't see any
so given that we have these two
amendments with their costs
which if any do we wish to recommend to
A legislature to bring forward this
um
certainly I don't recommend either one
of these because of the cost
I'll go back to what I had presented
before is that if we are trying to
retain officers
um
you know at 20 years and at 30 years we
can certainly raise the contributions by
a quarter of a percent each one of those
we've had the figures for that which are
greatly reduced from this
um and augment that with a uh the
ability for the the unions to negotiate
a match for voluntary contributions
which could be used by them for any
purpose they choose they could buy an
annuity with a cola in it they could you
know take the lump sum they could
whatever you can do with all that money
and they could do that and
certainly a much more fiscally
responsible
solution to this than either of the
Mr Campo well I would recommend that we
um
support 2258 because that's exactly what
we're trying to do we're trying to
retain our most experienced First
Responders
I think one of the issues that concerns
me with 2259 when a lot of these
significant changes were made we ended
up creating groups within the system so
you have people working side by side who
have different benefits yet who
experience the same risk and harm in
their job my concern with 2259 is you'd
uh actually it'd be three
because you would because you're
eliminated again you're eliminating
three groups no you're right the the uh
because you're the agency or don't
change all right so that is so that is a
concern that I have well that's fine but
I think 22.58 Mr Campo has cleanup that
we recommend 2258 which is
does not have that problem
are you looking for a second are we
under that would be a good idea I would
all right so that there's a
recommendation that we endorse Amendment
22 fight
2258 and recommend it to the legislature
and so it's open for discussion comments
Senator Bradley uh thank you very much I
appreciate
um the concern expressed by Senator
Susie the
um reason that I
ask for a multiplier that was
2.25 and 2.5 was because I thought that
we could have something that was more
affordable
um I can just
speaking for myself and I think
Senator gray already has echoed that the
92.6 million dollars I I just do not
know
how we
squeeze that into
a budget and an off year
um I I just don't know how we do it with
some of the requests that are already
being made you know sitting on fiscal
um I know that we're going to get a big
request from
the attorney general and administrator
Broderick or the YDC
um that's not all of one's funding but
it's certainly something that we have to
think about so I
cannot support
um
2259 uh 2258 because of the
huge impact
um
I do I continue to believe if we're
going to do something and you know 2258
I think is a better
um or 2259 is A Better Way Forward
it is more affordable but still it's 60
million dollars
um that is also a huge amount of money
that we're going to have to come up with
I think there are ways of dealing with
it
um
potentially
I'm not ready to recommend it at this
point in time I mean I just you know we
we talked about this before and I think
I presented these two amendments I we
had July revenues that were off by
um several million dollars we made up
most of that in August so the first two
months of this fiscal year we are barely
at even we're not running the kind of
surpluses that would allow us
uh to pay for a 59 or
a 92 million dollar appropriation I I
just
don't think we can do it I would hope
that
um all of us
would
want to make sure
that it's terminally funded
with the normalized cost being as Marty
talked about reflected in the
final numbers on both of the summary
sheets so that there's not a property
tax impact
um I think that would be very
problematic
um
so I can't support
it's a 92 million and I think it's
premature until we see September and
October revenues to make a
recommendation on the 59 and I think
that we also have to be willing and
maybe some of that is offline
discussions
um try to figure out how we might be
able to pay for that 59 million dollars
if we choose to go forward with that
Senator Waters
thank you madam chair and um
I will say I'm I'm a little anxious
about our moving towards the
recommendation or taking a vote I didn't
think actually that we were in the in
the moment of making motions and
seconding on on these at this point
because I share my colleague's concern
that
we need to have a bill that can be a
clean bill that potentially can go
um to the legislature on the veto day
and we'll deal with the most immediate
problem that we face which is doing
something about
about this and um
so I I I hear what is being said about
since we do have time through the fall
to have more Revenue numbers
um you know we are a commission we're
going to do what we're going to do but
we have a
legislature there are 424 people waiting
for us potentially on January 3rd and
um I think it really is our our duty as
a commission to come forward with a plan
which is going to have very substantial
support
um and bipartisan support so I I don't
know if there's a way for us to kind of
pause
um on on voting today because I don't
think I don't think we're quite ready to
make a vote uh
we could certainly pause or stop
anything we're doing
you know it's within our control
by what mechanism Senator were you
planning to have a bill for a vote on
I think if there is Broad support for
something
that's bipartisan
that the affected individuals
may not be everything they want but it's
a reasonable compromise
that
puts this issue to bed and we're not
debating it for the next
several sessions
and if there's that kind of broad
support from
um you know those of us who have to vote
on it those of us who would not us but
those who would benefit
from it
um and you know the support of
organizations
the association of counties the
municipal Association School boards
Association that you know that it's not
going to impact their budgets and and
the taxpayers that they represent I I do
think that there would be the
possibility of being able to move on
something whether it's on veto day or
whether it's
um very quickly in January with a you
know normal procedure bill that went
through hearings I I think that's I
think that's very possible
um but again it I think it's going to
take consensus and it's going to take
a willingness
um
you know for people to be willing to
compromise and and you know to get that
number down
to a point that it's affordable as we
are you know going into the
next budget with you know the likelihood
of more expenses for the YDC issue
um and probably other things too but uh
I
you know I'm an eternal officer you
certainly are Senator I'd like to
mention that I've noticed at least two
different bills on the topic and that's
only on the first day or so of of House
Bill submission so I do not believe that
there's any chance that we will
have a complete conclusion on all
pension issues I hate to disappoint you
but we're not that's not going to happen
Maybe
we'll see all right Mr rill
thank you madam chair
um you know just kind of listen to some
of the remarks about uh what we
anticipated the cost might be versus
what the cost actual actually is
um
you know I I
forgive me for feeling as though this
seems like somewhat of a moving Target
uh as far as what is going to be
affordable and what is not going to be
affordable
um you know we've talked about uh
bills that
you know House Bill 436 was I believe uh
and Mr Carlin correct me if I'm wrong uh
somewhere in the neighborhood of 134
million to get that fully funded
um while I'm surprised by the number uh
to amendment
2258. I do think it's worth talking
about where we think that Benchmark is
where we think that goal is
um for what is Affordable and what is
not
um I think we need to focus on what
brought us here in the first place and
that's that we have uh Public Safety
officers in every discipline are leaving
the job and what struck me uh is a bit
of a shock when we started this
discussion uh a few weeks back
we were talking about uh a finite number
of individuals and that number
happened to be incorrect because we had
a significant number of individuals who
have left the job since uh House Bill
4436 was unsuccessful and that trend has
been a trend that has been going on for
quite some time and what I'm worried
about here is that we're going to
continue to kick this can down the road
to a point that this number of of Public
Safety officers affected by uh
you know this bill or this group that
we're talking about specifically
um I'd hate to see that number dwindle
to a place where it then becomes
affordable because then we're dealing
with another problem and that's the lack
of firefighters police officers and
Correctional Personnel I think we really
need to take a good look at this
amendment
Senator Bradley I appreciate you
bringing it Forward
um to get the numbers on this I think if
we
could potentially talk about the
opportunity to fund it the same way that
we did House Bill 1587 last year I think
that there's some value to that and I
and I recognize
um wanting to have the luxury of
terminally funding
um but I I know that the costs uh the
downshift if if any was minimal on 1587
to the point that none of us uh actually
thought there was any
today when we when we talked to Mr
Carlin so I think it would be worth
looking at
um potentially funding the unfunded
piece uh to this this amendment and
continuing to move it forward to get it
done on veto day
anyone else have something to say Dad
Senator gray
um
one of the things that that I find very
interesting is you know we're trying to
set this thing up so that we save our
most experienced officers
fine
okay
proposal that I put in to raise the
multiplier at year 20 and year 30.
would affect all of the people in group
two
not the ones that are in this bracket
but all of the people who are in group
two
if we talk only about those people in
that bracket
and we're having this massive
retirement because of the retirement
system not being and I don't believe
that that's the real cause
then we're just pushing the can down the
road
and the money that we're talking about
because the difference between
a thousand eight hundred just to make a
median number
and the three or four thousand people
that are going either in that group that
aren't part of that
then what we're saying is they're going
to leave they're going to be gone
they're going to not be around
so if you if you fix for one group
and think that's going to solve this
thing forever
I think you should wake up I think you
should start drinking some coffee
okay because
you know negotiating wages
if I go back to on you know imagine a
lot of you have had Maslow's theories
okay is that I in Rochester what did I
do when I had a problem you know as a
member of the city council I raised the
wages I got more people to apply because
I raised wages I stopped the people from
going from Rochester down to Portsmouth
down to the state police down to other
things because I raised the wages okay
that's what I did
I didn't mess with the retirement system
because that wasn't what they were
asking for and which would be borne out
by Maslow's series I got to take care of
the wages first because I don't worry
about retirement until I get there
so saying well you know the problem's
going to go away no the problem isn't
going to go away and the funding is
going to increase and not decrease
because it's going to be those people
that are at the 10 11 12 year mark right
so
to cover the people you know that are in
that bracket
hey
divide the number that you're coming up
with by that total body count see what
the number is
and the constituents that come to me are
disturbed by that number
uh representative O'Brien
uh thank you uh Madam chair good to see
you again you know
um I'm representative Mike O'Brien uh
from Nashville I sit on Edna and I'm
pinch hitting today for uh
representative Leachman
uh I spent majority of my career within
the fire service and I am currently
retired but I also wear another hat
and that hat is a vice president of NASA
was born of alderman
I see all too much
the problems of people that are leaving
the job
because I mean another problem that's
out there it's not part of the pension
system but the drug problem other
different things that are occurring out
there in the city of Nashua I'm sure
Manchester is having the same thing it's
taking a toll
the firefighters and police officers of
our communities are getting burnt out
and they need to have something maybe
something from the state that says yes
we respect of what you do and we're
going to try to make uh you know
retirement a little bit better it's more
than an enticement
you know it's something that they
deserve they're giving an awful lot of
their time and I respect that
representative gray thank you for uh
mentioning Maslow I haven't heard that
name in a long time but part of the goal
of the retirement is to get to the
self-realization that is the end of the
goal in my maslode
I have reached that in my retirement
and so coming up with a vehicle to
really get us here and that's why if
this went to a vote today I'm going to
support uh 2258.
but the main reason I have worked within
the culture where you had to Workforce
divided
in the situation in Nashua it was with
sick time other different things the
infighting it wrecks the spirit Decor of
every organization
when at this particular juncture that
would you know some of the police
officers and firefighters are dealing
with on a daily basis they need to be
United to do their job
so in two uh 2258 there seems to
eliminate that particular problem so I
would support it
um and I'll leave that Madam chair at
that for now unless additional but I do
agree with uh brother real for those
things that he has said very accurate
and very true so I'll leave it at that
thank you
Mr real thank you madam chair
um
you know I I appreciate that we've all
come together here to try and get
something done I I don't want this to
turn into a
um a commission where we don't make
progress here and I'm I'm concerned that
that might be the direction uh we're
headed
um the one thing I'd like to say about
uh Senator Gray's thoughts on uh
increasing a
multiplier at years 25 and 30. we heard
from Mr Carlin a couple of weeks ago
stating that 25 and 30-year careers in
the police service and the fire service
and Corrections are not the norm and
that group one and group two
classifications were built off the fact
that group two uh tends to have
extremely hazardous occupations which
makes it even more difficult to reach
those 25 and 30-year benchmarks the
other piece to this
if we want to talk about impacting
everyone uh in the group 2 system which
I don't I'm not arguing against I think
that that is where we need to end up
eventually
um
new members coming on the job now uh are
required to put in 25 years of service
that means
if they get a uh they go from a 2.25
multiplier at year 25. to a year 30 to
get their two and a half percent
multiplier their pension is going to
increase by one and a quarter percent
no one is going to do that that's not
going to be a retention tool
and secondly to that uh Senator gray I
would like to agree with you on your
thoughts for a uh matching supplemental
retirement plan I think that that's an
excellent idea
um but that
we are eligible to do now
in contract negotiations that's
something that exists now in fact
um we run our own supplemental
retirement program and we encourage our
members to be involved in it so if a
local union wants to go to their
employer and negotiate the terms of a
matching contribution that can happen
now
thank you
all right
Mr Karen thank you madam chair just to
uh
two points of thought I can't find
myself
supporting any proposal unless we know
how it's funded most of you have more
experience their retirement system than
I do but my understanding is there's
three basic pockets of money to fund the
retirement system one is the employee
rates which are set in statute
the second are investment returns they
are what they are and the default of the
Delta are the employer rates so if we
set about to recommend any kind of
amendment that has a cost impact and
don't identify the source it's going to
default to the employer rates and that's
a significant issue the other issue I
like to raise is you know we all we all
live and work our own vacuums and dairy
may be different I'm not sure but when I
get on this committee I asked my HR
Director about our retention for our
group two people and if you can she
conducts exit interviews in the last two
years we've got about 130 folks in group
two with us at the town
we've had 27 people leave in the last
two years that's about 10 percent a year
of those 27 folks 12
had service retirements the eight they
attained the age of 45 or 20 years I
guess it's the category a folks we
unfortunately have four disability
retirements
we had six other folks who stayed in the
system but went to outside agencies
which is my signif other New Hampshire
agencies which is which is my challenge
of finding money to make our wages more
attractive
we had a medic who resigned to pursue a
nursing career
we had a patrolman who called the chief
of police on the night before the
academy and said this isn't for me
uh
we had one person go to Massachusetts or
one person to go to the government and
the last person was separated by
unfortunately our Direction and not
theirs so and of the 27 folks who had
left us two actually cited the pension
as a reason for doing something
different so Dairy could be different
but that's my sphere of information I
have currently thank you
thank you for the information
I know in my town when somebody leaves
it's because there's no opportunities
for for promotion in such a tiny
Department
there we go yeah they will go to Dairy
yes that's a better better opportunity
does anyone else have something that
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair I would just like to and uh
appreciate the numbers sir that you you
came up with uh and I wonder what's a
plethora of reasons why particular
people you know retire on any job they
can come up with any particular reason
why they break employment myself
personally I had a bunch of Young Bucks
I couldn't keep up with anymore
I thought I could
but I couldn't you know and it was time
for me to move on to Green the pastures
and I have
but uh you know
when you look at it I don't know if they
would really put that in complete
analysis but I would like to say when we
look at the firefighters in particular
they don't get out at 25 years
I didn't I stayed 35 and I found within
my group that a lot of firefighters
actually do stay longer than the 25
years so they should be granted some
form of uh entitlement for staying
within that longevity and making that
particular commitment I think I did ask
Mr Collins at one time in conversation
and he may have a number off the top of
his head but I'm not going to hold him
to it but the firefighters have been
as far as the longevity of the nhrs have
been a long-term contributor to the
program and somewhat deserving of any
Senator Bradley
yeah just a couple of things first of
all I think Senator Gray's proposal
starts at 20 years not 25
um so just correcting that
um a lot of the discussion about
different tiers and things like that the
retirement system has always had a
10-year vesting and
anybody you know for throughout the
history of the retirement system that
had less than 10 years has not been
vested so we've always had differing
tiers and and lastly I would say that um
as somebody who supported House Bill
1587 and the 42.9 million dollars
um
that we voted for I believe it was in
2022 that was terminally funded and
um no impact on property taxpayers to
get back to your point Dave I think
that's the only way
um that we should consider doing it I
had thought that
um you know when we passed 1587 that
some of these issues have been resolved
well clearly they haven't been
um but I think it needs to be said that
when we voted to appropriate 42.9
million dollars for
roughly 1800 people in a enhanced
retirement benefit
that was a pretty significant show of
good faith on the legislature's part on
a bipartisan basis so
surreal then representative O'Brien
thank you I just want to uh clarify
something that and maybe this is just
the difference of perspective but
um I don't think anyone uh that was
impacted by House Bill 1587 last year
interpreted that as an enhancement of
benefits that was a reinstatement of one
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair uh just something
for additional information for us to
chew on
um
like you say Recruitment and Retention
are big issues but with people leaving
and it is acute with people uh leaving
that means you have positions such as
firefighters or police officers
Corrections Officers that need to be
filled how do you fill that you end up
filling it in with overtime
that means yes maybe it might save on
some of the medical benefit but that
means when you come up and I can say
this from Nashua when we work out an
annual budget you try to keep it a
proper amount what you anticipate in an
overtime account but with people
disappearing on you
now that inflates that particular number
so you say where is the cost in spot of
the cost is being relayed in this
Delayed Action coming back to the
municipalities because they have to make
up the difference now in Nashua we have
how many firefighters we really want on
duty you know is it enough
maybe some may think so I've always
lived under the thing there may be too
many firemen right now in the city in
Nashua five minutes from now there may
not be enough
but the thing is we come try to come up
with a workable number but there is a
hidden cost that I want us to
contemplate as we sit here uh
backfilling these positions with people
that are vacating and that's by overtime
which is inflating Municipal budgets
anyone else have something to add or
Senator Susie
just want to go back to something that
my colleague Senator Waters said and
that is that I think everyone came to
the table wanting to do something and I
think Senator Bradley got that process
started now we have more information
but I do think we might need just a
little more and I would hate to see us
in a situation today where without that
missing piece of information about
additional funding or what the next two
months of Revenue looks like I'd hate to
see us divided in some way when I do
think we can hopefully all maybe not all
but pretty close get to yes so
um I
I think it might make sense to wait
until a later date to make a final
um my my two cents all right thank you I
appreciate that anyone else
Mr Speaker
I I think I uh definitely agree with uh
Senator Susie uh I'd hate to jump into
this thing and be divided
if we're going to pass this and we're
going to get something done and continue
to do things I think we all need to be
on the same page and if it takes another
couple three weeks to do that I think it
would be prudent for us to do that and
not jump ahead right now and pass
something that wow we're not going to
almost get unanimous consent on
right
Mr
be with the center and the uh speaker
and I'm willing to withdraw my
motion to pass 2258
all right thank you Mr real dude okay
all right so we if we need more
information I know the Senators want
information on
Revenue when do you think you will
have at least the next month's Revenue
so that you'll have a better feeling so
Revenue generally will know September
Revenue uh by October 3rd or 4th
um we'll know October revenues same time
in November
um
September is a very big Revenue month
that might give us enough information
but I mean the kind of numbers that
we're talking about
I I just speaking for myself I'm going
to feel a lot more comfortable
um having more information not less
um especially
because I keep stressing
I can't support anything that's not
terminally funded
um and I think that that's probably the
consensus on a bipartisan basis of
senators because the way that all of
these
um
some form or another of terminally
funding I I think that
in that case why don't we plan not to to
discuss these particular amendments
I would think that we'll have
September Revenue by October 5th okay
um October closes on a Sunday
um
so generally speaking it takes a couple
of days for Dra to put it together with
administrative services but Grant do you
yeah
okay
all right so that would
plan to meet on October 5th to discuss
this in light of September revenues
hopefully
um the other thing that I would very
much appreciate is if someone has a
specific
suggestion either for
this issue or any of the other issues we
were brainstorming about I would very
much like to have them in writing so
that we can look at them and know what
we're talking about
I have one that I'm going to be
mandatory overtime as defined by the
employer counts as base pay because that
brings up an issue that a lot of people
have commented to me about that there
are they're forced to work overtime
and they don't get credit for it so I
would like to put that in it's this very
simple Bill I'm not sure I'm a hundred
percent in favor of it but I think it's
simple enough to put in as a bill and
important enough to debate so I'll I'll
be putting that in this week
the commission can take a vote on to
endorse it or not but
I'll do it by myself so it's something
that I think we ought to do
Madam chair if you need a close sponsor
I believe that it will negate all of the
calculations that have been done uh up
to this point because it changes the
base of the salaries only going forward
um
again it's still when we talk terminally
funding
um well
sure that will come up and on other
topics when I was talking to people
about a voluntary contribution where the
the state or the local government could
match I was told that there wasn't
enabling legislation enough and that it
would require legislative action to be
able to do that so that their parameters
would be there that would require that
may or may not be the truth but that's
what I was told at the time and I bring
that up because we haven't talked about
Cola
we talked a great deal about colas well
without without coming to any real
conclusions except that they're nice to
get and and I thank you madam chairman
for your comment but you know I would
like to be able to to finish my thought
before before you do comment uh
that you know the two proposals that we
have here in front of us don't address
anything to do with code
and that is why I did come up with that
uh plan where if we had a match and
people put money in uh certainly when
the federal government changed from the
first from the Civil Service retirement
system to Furs I did put in money into
that system uh where there was no match
for civil service but I was able to use
that money you know later on to do other
things with and so I think that you know
we need to look at this as a whole which
is the way the legislation in House Bill
2 was written it wasn't written for any
particular house bill it was written for
us to have a free hand so
uh though both of those need to be come
into play when any of the solutions we
talk about
thank you Senator I would like to to
reiterate my request that if you have a
suggestion that you put it down
with numbers so that we can agree on
what we're talking about
could you bring that to the next meeting
um I've already supplied it to Marty
last uh spring I believe it was and we
can resurrect those emails and in
Fordham on to you with the numbers that
he calculated at the time for but it
does not include anything to do with the
match because the match would be
separate from the retirement system
completely okay and uh the only number
that I was given on that because it
would be a negotiated uh agreement
you know is that for the state portion
of it it would be uh in the 15 million
dollars but again that would be
thank you
sir
my apologies first for being a tardier I
got behind a tractor on the way here
from Keene to Concord and when you get
behind a literally a tractor just takes
a little bit more time
um my name is Chris Coates I'm the
County Administrator here in uh in
Cheshire county and
I've been listening to the conversation
I just wanted uh some clarity because I
I do feel that there are some some real
issues that we're facing in in Cheshire
county a rural rural area especially
when it comes to uh police and fire and
law enforcement across the board we're
seeing more and more that we're picking
up more and more towns and over having
oversight over towns because they can't
find people to go in and man those
positions
um and that's just putting more pressure
on our Sheriff's Department to do so and
on the fire side you know we're we're a
little bit different in Cheshire county
as we have more group one than we have
group two so uh Senator gray when you
said group one
um it was a little magic to my ears
um but but I also wanted to know from
Senator Bradley when you say terminal
just from my my knowledge that means a
one time and then it would be that we
would then have it passed down to us to
carry it's a balancing act I understand
I just wanted to make I just wanted a
clarity
so terminally funding would mean that we
authorized an appropriation
of whether it's in the amendment let's
just say
Amendment 2258 which is a straight 2.5
percent of 92.6 million dollars so we
appropriate that money it goes to the
retirement system and that is the
expectation that there will be no impact
on property taxpayers for the duration
of
the benefits being paid out to those
members and that's what's meant by
terminally funding
I appreciate I appreciate the uh the
Mr Martinez
Madam chair asked and be recognized
please thank you
um
I would like
to ask this question
we have
we're here because we recognize that
some changes were made
in a number of group two
workers were disproportionately affected
when we changed the deal on them
and we said we're going to calculate
your benefits differently for everybody
hired between 2002 and 2011. so we're
here to fix that problem
and I can't put a life of me
uh balance why we would need new money
for that
just think if I go to a bank and I put a
thousand dollars in that account and
then they tell me that everybody that
open account between 2000 and June 2011
will pay fees that nobody else will just
them
and I say that is wrong and then they'll
say okay that is right it is wrong and I
said okay well then give my money back
no we're gonna have to raise new Revenue
to make that fix
absolutely not
we need to follow the money and see what
the money went
employers pay their part citizen Town
pay their taxes investment returns came
in and workers paid their fair share of
what they were supposed to pay
so where is the money then
well it's at nhrs that's exactly what
the money is and that's what the fix
needs to happen
there
it's just a matter of fixing what we
want to fix we shouldn't have to go out
and say well taxpayer because if we use
the same terms
when we did this what we did
is we spiked
the pay down of the unfunded accrue
Library we did that and we say oh we
should have done that
but we can't go and double dip and ask
taxpayers to pay again because we want
to raise new Revenue
to cover a mistake that we've already
done and we know where the money is it's
just a matter of all the money
correct the thing and move on
you know yield thank you
I I think we should consider that
okay well that's
I
I think that what all the money that has
been paid in has been accounted for and
the trouble is that there's
we the legislature have been fiddling
with the retirement system so much
and the
going from a
irrational
plan
in the 90s and early 2000s who were a
sensible one means that there was a lot
that is not as you say sitting there
with the retirement the
retirement system calculates every two
years how much
needs to go in for the coming year and
that includes
all of the contributions that are there
and what they've got on hand it's not
like it's they're ignoring a few million
dollars sitting somewhere
may I follow up please
thank you madam chair
when we do such calculations and we say
for instance
that we're going to need six when we
calculate that we're going to have 6.75
percent Investments
and in 2022 we didn't get that right we
got minus six and a half
minus six and a half
we didn't go back and you say oh you
know this happened so we need to raise
new Revenue to cover up for the fact
that not only we didn't meet the 6.75
but we also were under six and a half so
taxpayers would have to pay that to make
we don't we don't do that but we do that
when we say we made
perhaps we went too far making this
calculation on folks that were in the
pipeline performing in the job expecting
the benefits to be calculated a certain
way and we change that on them and we go
back we say maybe we shouldn't have done
that how are we going to fix it well
we're going to have to raise new Revenue
we're not maybe we don't have the money
to find that in other words it's a
Fool's errant
I think simply we need to fix the
problem where the mistake was made
and if we realize and we accept that
they shouldn't have done the fastest
thing to do is to fix where it is
and I don't think we need to raise new
revenue for that it is a correction it's
Bradley I think it's important to
remember where we were in the 2010-11
time frame
um our unfunded liability was among the
worst in the country were under 60
percent funded as I recall we've
improved that dramatically rates for
employers were going through the roof at
that point in time to the point that
um
cities and towns were looking at not
being able to hire as many group two
people at that point in time and it it
took a long time to get there there's no
question about that it was sort of a
this deal that was made between
employers and employees employers were
underfunding the system employees
um were getting benefits that uh were
over and above what was mandated through
the special account
investment returns for that period of
time were also you know the expectation
because I sat on the board at the
Retirement Board I think in 2011
as I recall the investment return was
anticipated to be eight and a half
percent and it had been lowered from
nine percent to eight and a half and we
when I was on the board lowered it
um I believe it was to seven and three
quarters percent and it's been lowered
again that had to happen because that
was what was happening in real life so
you had those three factors of for years
employers not paying enough
I think it was 900 million dollars of
excess benefits that were taken out of
the Corpus to pay for
um you know things like the medical
subsidy and colos and
woeful
um investment returns
the only moving piece at that point in
time that
um where the impact was was on employer
rates and Dave I think you remember
exactly what that was like you were a
town manager then at the time and rates
were going through the roof
here we are 12 years later and I think
that
um
you know the folks at this table and
others who represent property taxpayers
whether it's County school or municipal
or even you know state taxpayers
the retirement system is in much better
shape than it was in 2011.
understanding we are trying
hopefully to rectify
um
some of the changes that were made but
it has to be affordable but there's no
money out there that is in the system
that could be used for this if we're
going to do this there's only a couple
of ways of doing it we could pass it on
to property taxpayers I've said that's
unacceptable it is unacceptable in my
view and I think most people in the
Senate would agree with that I'm not so
sure about the house but I would expect
that's the same or
we can terminally fund it and and that
takes consensus and compromise and
understanding what our budget picture is
um that's why you know I think it is
important that
we come back and have September revenues
that'll give us a snapshot we may feel
like we're in the same position
you know on October 5th that we are
today on September 14th but at least
we'll have you know September revenues
but to me that's
if we're going to you know go forward
with one of these amendments and change
the multiplier we've just got to know
where we're going because it is going to
take real dollars appropriated by the
state so that there's not an impact on
property taxpayers I I just
keep coming back to that I don't
those are the bad old days when
um when there were problems in the
retirement system the rates went through
the roof
and I distinctly remember what was
happening at that point in time rates
were going through the roof at cities
and towns schools Etc and citizen towns
were laying people off and we don't want
to see that happen again either so
that's why terminally funding is so
important
yes Mr Martinez thank you madam chair
appreciate the uh the comments and I do
remember in 2007 I was at the retirement
system as well but you don't have to be
there you know that we had a real
problem with Investments everybody knows
that S P 500 was valued lost 50 percent
of its value on a bear Market we thought
the world was ending and the sky was
falling and we did made some changes in
2011 finally by the time we got to the
legislation I'll say that some changes
were okay and some changes were good
but nothing said is changed the fact or
even tried the fact that a small number
of workers were disproportionately
affected by these changes and that's why
we're here today to correct that it is a
correction as we did the example of the
bank they short my account and I said
okay then can I have my money no we're
going to have to raise new revenues
maybe as taxpayers absolutely not nobody
here is saying that we should raise the
tax and there's no need for that the
economy did a lot better than that it
bounced back it's doing well the
retirement system is 62.5 funded our
fund is what 11 plus billion dollars at
that time was six billion that was
almost a double so it is no reason why
we're gonna leave that 1867 workers
waiting there until we win the Mega Box
or or raise new Revenue knew all this
stuff it is
what it is it is a correction we know
where the money is we follow the money
and it's just a thing that it needs to
be done this is really if this thing
went to a tax I'll be the first one to
say there's no reason to raise a
property tax on that all we need to do
is do our job and make the correction
where the error was made and I would say
it wasn't narrow to do that because they
are disproportionately affected
by that it is bad enough that we raised
two percent of of the uh the
contribution with no actual benefit but
in addition we changed the way you do
the calculation they they were in the
pipeline performing on the job expecting
that I understand the concept of vesting
all it means that investing you are
vested but the terms of the deal is the
same thing that the courts set for the
judges they tried to change the patient
for judges and what did the court said
in the decision of Claudia versus the
state of New Hampshire 2012 says no you
cannot change because judges expected
these benefits will stay what they are
when they are performing the job they
did that correctly but somehow
we are where we are we can we can change
that we think that it is not very funny
for a worker that can pay their bills or
retire with less benefits than they were
promised
thank you
before
thank you I just want to build on those
comments and make a particular
suggestion and ask so what we do with
the information will be a conversation
for another day but I feel it's
important that we actually get a number
for that and to actually find out how
much was paid into it because I know I
don't know the answer to that so I'd be
curious how much how much money was so
for those 10 years for instance with the
extra two percent that both groups paid
in I'd be curious to know what that
number was because I agree with Senator
Bradley that the retirement system is in
a much better shape today and the more
information we have of that condition I
think that would be helpful for our
discussion number one and number two I'm
just building on what you asked for
before
um several of us made some suggestions
at the last meeting so it would be nice
to be able to get some Actuarial numbers
for those proposals so that we would
have more information because I also
would like to agree with Senator gray in
that I think coming out of here it's for
this to really work
we need to really deal with the whole
problem
and I happen to think that if we do that
and we might not be able to do
everything like right now but if we have
some more information for maybe
short-term and long-term plan I think
that would be helpful for us okay I
who don't have a set of a plan with a
set of numbers that we could give to the
actuaries we talked about a lot but
there wasn't a specific let's try this
that we would that we could send to the
actuaries if you could try and generate
that or get with some other people
whatever because you need to have a
specific plan before you can Bob
the actuaries have no imagination and
they can't fill in the blanks
yeah so if you could come up with
something I would it would be very
helpful for us to be able to take a look
I don't care
excuse me Senator gray and then Mr Earl
along those lines about getting the
numbers we were handed the chart that
was made by the retirement system and
handed it to us on 824 I would like as
these proposals go on to add those to
the charts so that we have the
information in a very handy and I will
note that on the top of page two of that
is the proposal that I talked about and
the cost information for that on that
chart absolutely I will look at that
Mr rail
thank you madam chair I just like to ask
a question because procedurally I'm not
sure how this works not being a
legislator myself
um understanding that we're going to
wait to see what revenues do I'm fully
fully on board with that
um but seeing as how this was a uh this
commission was built from an amendment
off of last year's budget is there any
opportunity to use any uh funding from
last year or surplus funds to fund
some or all of any of these amendments
certainly if there is any
the last I I heard the Surplus was
almost entirely in the education trust
fund which would
not be able to be used that way
but I could be wrong Senator uh
um what didn't go into the education
trust fund went into the rainy day fund
at the close fiscal year uh but those
numbers won't be uh actually calculated
until we do the audit so uh right now uh
as of the end of June
um what money was there went into a
particular spot and if it was left over
it went into the rainy day fund and it
would take legislation I believe to take
it out of there that's why we're talking
about what the current revenues are uh
from July August and then we'll look at
September Etc because that would be more
likely the funding source that you would
use to try and fund anything you try to
do here
Senator gray uh would that be if you
know would that be something that would
be accessible uh legislatively through
this if it was added to this amendment
to get access to the that that funding
again
you know things are possible you know uh
but again
you know the harder the more stuff you
put in there the harder it is I'm going
anyone else have something
but representative thanks Madam chair I
think we've been talking a lot about the
cost of action and I I'm glad that uh
representative O'Brien uh as well as Mr
Karen talked about uh you know what's
the cost of inaction
um and I think that
it'll be important for us to come back
to the table I'm not sure there's any
specific research requests but I I do
think that we all bring with us
perspective and stories
you know qualitative and quantitative
data around uh the cost of us not uh
being able to to send something forward
to the legislature uh in January so
um it's good that we're we're you know
hopefully going to model out some other
uh ideas and proposals we're going to
talk about Cola moving forward I think
there's good sort of long-term
short-term uh
kind of actionable things that we can do
but let's let's let's also figure out
what the what the impact of of inaction
is
um which will hopefully
um Inspire us to move something forward
okay
okay here we are the middle of September
we won't have the September revenue for
three weeks
do we
please
I wanted to raise my hand for that
um thanks Senator gray for clarifying
your numbers are in that grid already
and I will add these two amendments into
that grid and resend it send a fresh
copy
um question came up earlier from
commissioner Fuller about how much more
members have been paying and
um without
I can give you a reasonable ballpark
um basically you know the contribution
rates for members went up two percent
for employees and teachers and a little
bit more for police and fire two and a
quarter two and a half but just just for
the sake of using round numbers if you
assume employee employees members are
paying two percent more the total
payroll uh in 2011 was 2.5 billion so
two percent of that is 50 million so you
know members through increased
contributions were putting in about 50
million more than you know increasing as
payroll grew over the the last 12 years
uh fiscal 22 we were just a little bit
over 3 billion so a little bit in excess
of 60 million so you're talking 10 or 12
years at 50 million so that's you know
that's the that's the ballpark what
you're looking at in terms of what
members have been contributing uh since
the rate the member contributions were
raised back in 2011 and
while it's not a complete one for one
every dollar the member puts in the
employer doesn't have to pay it's it's
it's pretty close but you know because
people withdraw and get their
contributions back there is some some
some bleed out on those those member
contributions but
um you know that was that was one of the
things the increased member
contributions is what uh stabilized and
lowered the rates briefly uh back after
HP to change that plus the totality of
the benefit changes so just figured
you'd ask that so and I knew the answer
um quite as the representative Wilhelm
you know the the short answer for you
know the longer you wait to restore
benefits already you know for peep
service are already accrued the more
it's going to cost every year we had a
similar bill I think in 2018 or 19 to
restore group two benefits more or less
similar to uh 436 and I think it was the
unfunded was 140 million for the full
bolt and it was over 200 five years
later when it came back up again in 2023
so the reason for that is when we talk
about what the unfunded liability is on
changes like this where it's actually
changing the benefits and reverse is
that that amount is what we should have
in the trust fund now had it been funded
in an orally fashion over the past 12
years
um so that that's that's how those those
that's what those numbers are
um I hope I didn't make anything more
confusing I was I was trying to help and
and the last thing was in terms of um
retirement ages and and service there
was a chart we provided in advance of
the commission it may or may not be on
the website it's it's Service retirement
so over the last 10 years by group and
it's got the average age and average
service for the different member groups
uh that doesn't obviously since it's
Service retirement it doesn't count
people who choose to leave the
profession early
um it's only the retirees I don't have
the numbers in front of me so I don't
want to cite them but they're out there
okay are there any more questions from
Mr Carlin well we've got them in the hot
seat
okay I think not thank you very much
thank you volunteering recognizing me
okay so if we're meeting on
the fifth to to review Revenue estimates
and the cost of these I'd also like to
have a meeting before then to discuss
some other changes that people are going
to
document so that we can we can compare
them and decide if we want to
go ahead with an Actuarial analysis
is there a preference for next week or
but all right Senator Susie votes for
the 28th
okay
the speaker votes for the 28th is there
any objection to meet to skipping next
all right I don't see any so we'll do
that
um
if anyone does have want to present a
plan with so that we can discuss it and
decide if we want to to have it analyzed
please send it to to me and I'll
disseminate it to the commission
um
all right thank you very much and I'll